before we dive in i have a little
announcement to make which is why my
culinary partner in crime palar valdez
is joining me
hey drew hi pilar good morning good
morning
um okay so for the past several months
we have been working
on a very special project that is oh so
near and dear to our hearts and i feel
like i'm about to burst
because i'm so everyone i'm so excited
to tell everyone about it
how do you feel about it palar very very
excited
it's like um feels like a birth
announcement
it does yeah um okay so you all know
at the show if you've ever watched it
how much we love cookbooks how much we
embrace it and we actually have
cookbook club which is a very important
part of the show so
guess what we
wrote a cookbook
we've been working on it for i mean what
feels like
a long time a long long time and it
actually comes out november 2nd but you
guys are going to get an exclusive look
at the cover palaar are you ready to
reveal
i am ready whoo okay i just got nervous
and excited i know
i know oh my god
[Music]
[Applause]
we were so insane about the graphics and
look there's
pilar and by the way when you open the
book as i will show you now we'll give
you a little sneak peek inside
um the first picture that you'll see is
myself and pilar holding hands
and um because we really are dear
friends
we met through food and cooking
absolutely i mean it's been such a
wonderful journey i feel like
when we first started working together
it was around like a
the kitchen island you know and we had
like cookbooks and we were just sharing
stories talking about food
and then that's where i think the idea
of the cookbook
was born drew is like such a tremendous
dreamer
and you dreamed it up i had not even
considered
i have to say too i met you at a point
in my life where i was living in a
rental apartment i was moving from los
angeles
to new york uh i was looking to start
new endeavors so that i could be home
with my kids i was like i'll start a
company i'll write a book i'll do
anything like
how can i be a mom first and my life
felt very unanchored
and there was a lot of transition and i
met you at that time
and we ended up dreaming and finding an
anchor together
and you and food and our friendship
was a huge saving grace for me
and something i could hook into when my
life felt so floating and here we are
three years later
and i feel like our lives are so
anchored individually and together
absolutely we're totally tethered
together i mean us meeting was like
you know serendipity and a whole lot of
luck i think
i do think for anyone who's out there
who makes a connection with someone
and you want to do something together go
for it because i couldn't do this alone
yeah and i think it's so much about
relationships and community just like
what you're saying
and i think that's one of the reasons
why we gravitated also towards food
because
for me cooking is so much about feeding
other people right it's about
the other people the people around the
table and this cookbook
is just about opening up that table
inviting more people in so i'm really
really psyched you're so altruistic
pilar
food for me is just about shoveling it
in my face but that's my joy good for
you
to take care of everyone else i just
want to manchester
and you're all going to get an exclusive
sneak peek today because we're also
going to make
one of the recipes from this book and we
picked
something special just for you guys
today and here's a little back story
about my
incredible friend and partner in
culinary crime who i found in the world
luckily enough and we decided to do this
together so
i wanted to show you a little back story
shall we get cooking
let's do it for pilar and i it was love
at first bite
i love you love you food has brought us
together pilar and i met three years ago
and we've cooked up some amazing meals
ever since
you know what this needs more than
anything tons of lemon zest
on top after it's cooked when we're
together it's wonderful right because
we're like just
riffing off of each other release the
juice and the juices
wait until you get to glue the arugula
the glue glue we basically speak our own
love language
all our love notes to each other are
doggy eared recipes and
photos of food on instagram this is a
true
original just like you pilar thank you
i love you my time with drew has really
been about
embracing the yes i've learned so much
from heart
i couldn't do it alone i could only do
it with pilar thank you